je ne peux pas te laisser faire ça jason je ne
voulais pas le dire avant que ta famille ne
s'implique mais elle n'est pas la seule pour
lui tu l'as dit toi-même non je n'ai pas
dit que
c'était bien plus gênant que je ne
le pensais  va être
bonjour jason tu dois venir m'aider
enfin quelqu'un retourne un appel téléphonique
arrête d'être un connard pendant une seconde je suis
nu au milieu du mexique je suis
descendu à la station pour récupérer tracy je me
suis fait sauter ils ont pris ma voiture et ils ont
pris  mes vêtements je devrais être marié et
en lune de miel mais à cause de toi
ils vont m'avoir nous avons tous vu le
film pris personne ne prend personne
hey ne me tire pas dessus ne me tire pas dessus oh dieu dis
nous le  comment tu t'appelles je te
rembourserai pour toute la cocaïne
nous avons un énorme problème on ne peut pas porter la cocaïne d'un homme
autour de
nardo a des problèmes au mexique il est allé
chercher tracy on doit aller le trouver
vous allez marcher jusqu'au mexique non non
Non, je suis désolé,
allez, je dois prendre une carte d'identité avant d'
arriver au Mexique,
chérie, que se passe-t-il,
qui es-tu, tes amis sont Kenny,
tu me fais une fausse carte d'identité, la vérité est qu'ils
m'ont donné cet argent pour prendre des photos
de mes couilles.
wow c'est
une mission de sauvetage
pas un voyage en voiture
tracy tracy
noro où es-tu je suis dans une prison mexicaine
qui est ce gars
va t'en prendre à cette fille amusons-nous es-
tu sûr de vouloir faire ça oui pourquoi
je ne le ferais pas
comment  est-ce que tu as des relations sexuelles sans attendre une minute
est-ce que tu prends mon rein je ne
prends généralement pas les enfants par derrière c'est ce que fait le
médecin